Here's how I would close if I was delivering a  talk to university students...
...about discovering their talents and strengths.
For some of you, this may be the last time we see each other.
But before we part ways, I need to remind you that we all have superpowers.
You deserve to be successful and to express all of your hidden talents.
I believe in you.
In closing, I have one ask.
Don't give up on yourself.
Look inside yourself and I promise that you will find it.
It might not happen straightaway, but keep searching.
Keep looking and you will find your gift.
I want to say a massive "Thank you" to Allie King.
Thank you so much for putting this event together.
None of this would have been possible if it wasn't for her.
Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you so much for showing up.
I enjoyed each and every second  we had together.
Have an amazing day and I'll see you on the next one.